a few years back leaders entrepreneurs
and innovators formed companies whereas
managers were hired to run their
operations but nowadays you will notice
that our educational system is
increasingly focusing on management
education while downplaying the value of
leadership
also there is a perspective change that
treats both management and leadership as
the same which is not a mere reality
so today in this video we're going to
take a deep dive into the most commonly
used words in the business environment
leadership and management
but before we begin make sure to
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
that bell icon to never miss an update
from simplylearn an organization is led
by two people
a leader who sets the vision or goals
and a manager who paves the path to
reach those objectives with the
assistance of his subordinates to put it
another way management is an ability to
climb the ladder of success
whereas leadership is the capacity to
make sure that the ladder is against the
right wall
moving forward let's first understand
what leadership is all about
leadership is the process of driving
constructive non-incremental change
through meticulous planning vision and
strategy
workforce empowerment and adaptive
decision making also add up to the
crucial attributes of leadership
to become a leader you are not required
to hold an authoritative figure in the
organization a leader is someone who
always takes the initiative and invests
a great effort to accomplish the
company's vision
that is the only reason why people
around start following them
leaders in general are those who
question the status quo
they are incredibly adaptive change
savvy visionary agile and creative
we have a dedicated video on leadership
skills here's a video link to that
now let us understand what management is
management is all about completing
pre-planned tasks with the support of
subordinates on a recurring basis
a manager is completely responsible to
carry out the four important functions
of management planning organizing
leading and controlling
managers can become leaders if they
adequately carry out leadership
responsibilities which include
communication of good and bad
providing inspiration and guidance and
encouraging employees to rise to a
higher level of productivity
but unfortunately not all managers can
achieve that
managerial responsibilities are often
outlined in a job description with
subordinates following because of the
professional title or classification a
manager's primary focus is meeting
organizational goals
they often do not take much else into
consideration
with the title comes the authority and
the privilege to promote
hire or reward employees based on their
performance and behaviour
moving ahead we will look into the
differences between leadership and
management
the first area of difference is vision
leaders are considered as visioners
they set the path to excel the
organizational growth
they always examine where the
organization stands where they want to
go and how they can reach there by
involving the team in paving a future
path
in comparison managers set out to
achieve organizational goals by
implementing processes such as budgeting
organizational structuring and staffing
managers vision is bound to the
implementation strategies planning and
organizing tasks to reach the objectives
set out by leaders
however both of these roles are equally
important in the context of business
environments and necessitate associative
efforts
the next field of differentiation is
organizing versus aligning
managers pursue objectives through
coordinated actions and tactical
processes
they unfold targeted vision into small
stages and organize available resources
to achieve the desired result
leaders on the other hand are less
focused on how to organize people and
more on finding ways to align and
influence them
they accomplish this by helping
individuals envision their role in a
larger context and the future growth
potential their efforts can provide
the third distinction between a manager
and a leader is that a leader asks the
questions what and why
whereas a manager focuses on the
questions how and when
to do justice to their duties as a
leader one might question and challenge
the authority to reverse decisions that
may not be in the better interests of
the team
if a firm has a stumbling block a leader
will be the one to step up and ask what
did we learn from this
and why has this happened
managers on the other hand are not
compelled to evaluate and analyze
failures
their job description stresses asking
how and when
which helps them ensure that plans are
carried out appropriately
they prefer to accept the status quo as
it is and do not strive to change it
the final factor on our list is position
versus quality a manager is a role that
frequently refers to a specific job
within a organization structure
whereas the term leader has a more
ambiguous definition
leadership emerges as a result of your
actions if you are a leader and act in a
way that inspires others to do their
best it makes no difference what your
title or position is
a manager on the other hand is a job
title that comes up with a predefined
set of obligations
leadership is a great quality that can
make a significant difference in your
respective careers
and with passing time you can shape it
by developing emotional intelligence and
learning how to influence others
leading and managing are two contrasting
ways of making the employees work
together more efficiently
leadership is a spearhead for the new
vision and initiatives whereas
management controls the resources
effectively to bring those visions into
the realm of reality that's all that we
have for today i hope this video is
helpful to all of you out there and i
wish you all the very best thank you for
watching the video and stay tuned for
more from simply learn
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here